للمره الاولى بوتين يزور المناطق الخاضعه
للسيطره الروسيه باوكرانيا ويتفقد
ماريوبول
شرطه نيويورك تتاهب لاحتجاجات المحتمله
على خلفيه مذكره اعتقال ترامب
كوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخا باليستيا
جديدا وطوكيو وصول تحت الجانب بشده
[موسيقى]
اعلنا الكريم ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين قام بزياره عمل الى ماريوبل في
دنيات لتفقد مواقع المدينه ومرافقها ووفق
البيان فان بوتين سافر الى ماريوبل بطائره
هليكوبتر ثم استقل سياره ليتجول بها في
انحاء المدينه وبين الحين والاخر يقف
قليلا للتحدث الى السكان واشار الكراملين
الى ان بوتين التقى بالقياده العليا
لعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
المسؤول عن حرب موسكو في اوكرانيا
الينا حول هذه الزياره من موسكو مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد
الجواد يعني لاول مره بوتن بجوله تفقديه
ميدانيه الى ماريوبل ماذا في تفاصيل هذه
الجوله
صباح الخير راويه نعم بالفعل يعني
بنشر الخبر حول زياره العمل هذه طبعا ما
يلفت للانتباه هنا بان هذه الزياره جاءت
اما في ساعات متاخره من ليله الامس او
صباح اليوم باعتبار ان كافه مقاطع الفيديو
التي يقود فيها
السياره في مدينه ماريوبل كان الظلام يحل
في المكان طبعا راويه لابد من لفت
الانتباه الى ان بوتين اجرى هناك العديد
من الاجتماع ابرزها كان الحديث مع نائب
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الروسي الذي تحدث
بتفصيل عن وضع ماريوبل اليوم واعاده
الاعمار وكيف يتم الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
قضيه المحافظه على شكل وبنيان المدينه
خلال عمليه اعاده الاعمار ايضا تقدم
ممثل مجلس الوزراء لبوتين بالحديث عن ان
سكان المدينه بداوا بالعوده شيئا فشيئا
الى منازلهم والى المناطق التي كانوا
يسكنوا بها ايضا تحدث عن العروض
الاقتصاديه الكبيره التي تقدمها الان
الحكومه الروسيه في تلك المنطقه لفت
الانتباه الى ماريوبل وهي تقطيم قروض
لاصحاب الاعمال يمكنهم الحصول عليها لفتح
المحل التجاريه على الطوابق الاولى من
الابنيه التي يتم تشييدها وهي تحظى باللون
الابيض الملفت ايضا للانتباه راويه هو
الحديث الجاري عن مد طريق سريع وافتتاحه
بين مدينه ماريوبل ودنيس طبعا هذه المدينه
هي بحاجه لهذا الموضوع اتذكر جيدا الساعات
الخمس او السته التي كنا نقطعها بين مدينه
دانيتسكو الموضوع اليوم فهو يحتاج لساعه
فقط هذا الطريق قد يعيد الحركه التجاريه
باعتبار ان ماريوبل لها اطلاله كبيره
وميناء على البحري يمكن منه تصدير البضائع
من دانيتك ومن تلك المنطقه هي زياره طبعا
اولى يرى فيها الكثير راويه اهتماما خاصا
خاصه انها تاتي بعد يعني سلسله التصريحات
الناريه التي اطلقتها موسكو بما يخص قضيه
مذكره الاعتقال للرئيس الروسي والتي راى
فيها الكثير من المحللين السياسيين في
البلاد لانها تاتي للتشويش وعلى زياره
الرئيس الصيني المتوقعه والمنتظره يوم غد
ايضا طبعا بوتين اراد ايصال رساله بانه
يمكنه التحرك من قبل هذا الموضوع وان
موسكو تسيطر على الوضع في هذه المنطقه هذه
هي ابرز القراءات السياسيه طبعا خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه سيخرج العديد من
المحللين ويتحدثون عن زياره اوتيل الى
ماريوب التي تشكل اهميه كبيره شكرا جزيلا
لك من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الراشد
والان مشاهدينا في هذه الاخبار العاجله عن
قياده العمليات المشتركه العراقيه
بتصريحات خاصه للعربيه لن نسمح بتداول
الاسلحه والعبث بامن المواطنين وايضا لا
سلاح فوق سلاح الدوله كما ان نؤكدت
العمليات المشتركه العراقيه للعربيه بانه
لا توجد اي قوه قتاليه اجنبيه خارج مهام
التدريب وبانها اكملت عمليه الانتشار لضبط
الحدود مع تركيا وايران وكانت وكاله تسنيم
الايرانيه قد اعلنت منذ قرابه النصف ساعه
ان شمخانسه وقع في بغداد وثيقه امنيه
مشتركه مع العراق نتابع باطار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث ان الرئيس
الاوكراني حذر الدول التي تساعد روسيا ضد
بلاده بان مصيرها العزله في العالم ولم
يحدد زيلينسكي في كلمه مسجله بثها عبر
حسابه على تويتر اسماء تلك الدول لكنه قال
ان من ضمنها دوله تزود روسيا بطائرات
مسيره من نوع شاهد التي تنتجها ايران
واضاف الرئيس الاوكراني ان هناك مساعدات
عسكريه جديده تشمل ذخيره ودبابات ومدافع
قادمه لبلاده من كندا والمانيا وفرنسا
والدنمارك واستونيا
اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان بخمو لا
تزال بؤره المواجهات العسكريه في المعارك
ضد روسيا واشارت في بيانها اليومي الى ان
القوات الروسيه شنت 11 هجوما صاروخيه من
بينها اربعه هجمات استهدفت بنيه تحتيه
حيويه في زابوريا وذكر البيان ايضا ان
سلاح الجو الاوكراني استهدف سبعه مناطق
انتشار للقوات الروسيه بعشره ضربات جويه
اعتبرت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا ان اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مذكره توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
قرارا بالغ الاهميه وشددت كولونا على ان
هذه الخطوه رادعه لانها تعني ان اي شخص
مسؤول عن اي نوع من الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
يجب ان يحاسب بغض النظر عن وضعه او منصبه
مضيفه انه لا توجد اي حلقه في السلسله
يمكنها ان تعتقد انها ستفلت من العداله
اكدت اداره شرطه نيويورك لوكاله نوفوستي
انها في حاله تاهب واستعداد لمواجهه اي
احتجاجات محتمله على خلفيه نداء وجاهو
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
لمناصريه ودعوته لهم للاحتجاج واضافت شرطه
نيويورك انها ستبقى على اتصال وتنسيق مع
شركائها في الحكومه واجهزه انفاذ القانون
للمحافظه على سلامات العامه وكانت وسائل
الاعلام قد ذكرت ان ترامب قد يواجه
اتهامات الاسبوع المقبل فيما يتعلق بدفع
اموال للممثله ستورميدانيز مقابل التزامها
الصمت بشان علاقتهما المزعومه الا ان
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب نفى العلاقه
واي اعمال غير قانونيه ورفض الادلاء
بشهادته امام هيئه المحلفين كما انتقد
ترامب مكتب المدعي العام بمنطقه منهات
واصفا اياه بالفاسد والمسيس للغايه
اعلان ترامب على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تروس سوشل بانه سيتم اعتقاله الثلاثاء
ومطالبته لانصاره بالتظاهر دعما له فجر
قنبله سياسيه في الاوساط الامريكيه تصريح
ترامب اعاد الى الاذهان مشهد السادس من
يناير واقتحام مبنى الكابيتال الامر الذي
استدعى استنفارا امنيا وقضائيا فالمسؤولون
في نيويورك ناقشوا الترتيبات الامنيه في
محكمه من هاتنا الجنائيه في حاله صدور
لائحه اتهام
في امريكا الكل هو تحت القانون ولكن ما
يمكن ان يحصل في حال ان حصل الادعاء واريد
ان اوضح هنا ان الادعاء يجب ان يصول
المحلفين واذا كان هناك تصويت
فباغلبيه
[موسيقى]
يعني اتهام ترامب
رسميا يستطيع الرئيس ترامب ان يذهب بنفسه
الى المركز الشرطه وطبعا
يسلم نفسه
تصريحات ترامب قبلت على الفور بالمواقف
السياسيه الداعمه حتى اللحظه ففي الوقت
الذي اعتبر رئيس مجلس النواب كيف المكارتي
ان قرار اعتقالي ترامب ليس سوى اساءه
استخدام شنيعه للسلطه من قبل مكتب المدعي
العام سارع احد ابرز المنظمين لليله
الكابيتال علي الكسندر لتاييد ترامب
والاعلان عن استعداده لتنظيم مسيرات ترفض
قرار المدعي العام بحال صدوره
تواكب على الارض دائما ولكن ليس لهم دور
اساسي في هذا الموضوع الشرطه في نيويورك
لها الدور الاساسي وبداوا يتحضرون باي
محاولات شغب او لتظاهرات كبيره قد تؤدي
لاعمل
[تصفيق]
من المحتمل ان يجمع اعتقال ترامب اذا تم
الخطوات الروتينيه التي يواجهها كل متهم
من اخذ البصمات والتصوير مع كل الخصائص
الممنوحه لرئيس سابق كما يرافق جهاز
الخدمه السريه الامريكيه كل تحركاته
اعتبر خبر اعتقال ترامب
افضلها تلقاها المرشح الاول للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله لان القنبله الموقوته
تبقى في دعوه
الامر الذي سيشكل نقطه نقاشات حاده في
الايام المقبله سليمان العربيه واشنطن
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
في فرنسا النقابات تتواعد الحكومه بتوسيع
اضراباتها لتشمل قطعي الطيران والتعليم
غدا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقاليه السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
ان القوات المسلحه تمتلك كل الامكانيات
لتنفيذ مطلبات الشعب الخدميه مؤكدا ان
القوات المسلحه لن تتخلى عن واجباتها
بتنفيذ كل ما يطلب منها لتحقيق هذه
المتطلبات
[تصفيق]
عندنا
تنظيمات وجهات مسؤوله من تنفيذ مظالم
الناس
نحن بنعلم استوى
وبتتعالج بورق بكتابه اذا كان تعديل
قوانين للروائح لنظم لكل شيء ده حق الناس
نحن ما نتاخر فيه ولا حنجيب فيه مما جئنا
سمعناه وسمعنا كلام الناس انه جيش واحد
شعب واحد حق الجيش ده حقكم انتم ما حق اي
زول ثاني ولا حق جانا ولا حق زيد ولا حق
عبيد عشان كذا لما قلنا حنجيب الاسعافات
هنجيب من الجيش اداريه حنجيبها من الجيش
العبارات حتقطع الناس حنجيبها من الجيش
القلابات هنجيب لنا قلابات اربعه قلابات
وحنجيب لوادر حنجيبهم من الجيش هنا
اطلاق جارتها الشماليه صاروخا بالستيا
انتهاك لقرار مجلس الامن فيما افادت وزاره
الدفاع اليابانيه بان اليابان احتجت بشده
على اطلاق الصاروخ وذلك من خلال سفاره
جاء ذلك بعدما اطلقت كوريا الشماليه
صاروخا باليسيا باتجاه البحر الشرقي وفق
هيئه الاركان المشتركه في الشغل وقد اطلقت
الخميس اقوى صاروخ لها تحت اسم هو سونج 17
الباليستيه العابر للقارات وتعتبر عمليه
اطلاق هذه الاحدث وتتزامن مع اجراء السيول
واشنطن اكبر مناورات عسكريه مشتركه بينهما
منذ خمس سنوات والتي تستمر لعشره ايام
افدى مراسل العربيه بان الشرطه الفرنسيه
اعتقلت 80 متظاهرا في باريس في احتجاجات
دخلتها اعمال شغب واشتباكات مع الشرطه
لليوم الثالث على التوالي واستخدمت شرطه
مكافحه الشغب الغاز الموسي للدموع لتفريق
المحتجين اشتبكت مع البعض بعد اشعال النار
في صناديق القمامه وتمثل الاضرابات
والاضرابات المتزايده المضاده اخطر تحدا
لسلطه رئيس ايمانويل ماكرون وحكومته
الساعه الى تمرير مشروع اصلاح لنظام
التقاعد برفعه عامين الى 64 عاما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وحول استمرار الاحتجاجات قلم مراسل
العربيه ان النقابات اعلنت عن الدخول في
اضراب يوم الاثنين المقبل يضم قطاعات عده
منها التعليم والملاحه الجويه مشيرا الى
ان حركه الطيران ستشهد اضطرابا والغاء
للكثير من الرحلات
وهذا ما تقوله ان نقابات ان الاضراب الذي
سيبدا في الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر
سيضم قطاعات اضافيه يوم الاثنين المقبل
ايضا سيشهد اضطرابا في حركه الطيران اعلن
موظفوه مراقبه الملاحه الجويه انهم
سيضربون ابتداء من يوم الاثنين المقبل
وسوف يتم الغاء تقريبا 30% من الرحلات من
مطار اورلي بالاضافه الى مطار 20% من
الرحلات في مطار مدينه مارسيليا جنوب
البلاد لكن هناك دعوات كثيره للاضراب هناك
قطاعات كثيره تدعو للانضمام لاضراب هناك
اضراب سيقوم به المدرسون يوم الاثنين
المقبل
نذهب لنستمع لكلمه رئيس الوزراء العراقي
في ذكرى مرور 20 عاما على الغزو الامريكي
مباشره
الذي يشهد هذه الايام لله الحمد
اقامه مثل هذه المؤتمرات
فقبل ايام كنا حاضرين في ملتقى السليمانيه
واليوم نتواجد هناك في هذا المؤتمر في
بغداد
وهذه علامه صحيه ومضيئه تدل على ان العراق
استعاد مكانته الطبيعيه
حاضنا للحوارات والمؤتمرات والفعاليات
بمختلف
مسمياتها الحضور الكريم
نقف اليوم على اعتاب الذكرى العشرين
للسقوط النظام الديكتاتوري البغيض
مستذكرين الام شعبنا ومعاناته في تلك
السنين التي سادتها الحروب العباسيه
والتخريب الممنهج
وعزلتنا عن مواكبه التطور والتقدم
حتى جاءت لحظه التغيير في عام 2003 وصار
شعب العراق صاحب القرار في رسم مستقبل
البلد
فتقاترت جموع العراقيين في سنه 2005 نحو
صناديق الاقتراع
بانتخابات نيابيه
تتحدى القذائف الصاروخيه التي كانت تتساقط
على مراكز الاقتراح
والهجمات الارهابيه الانتحاريه وهي تتربص
بهم عند كل ناصيه وزاويه
ثم بعدها بدات تحدي الاهم في السنه نفسها
وهو اختيار دستور دائم ينهي الحاله الشاذه
التي سار عليها النظام الديكتاتوري الذي
صاغ دستورا مؤقتا يوافق مزاجه من دون اي
اعتبار او مراعاه للحقوق الاساسيه لجموع
العراقيين
فاختار العراقيون في الخامسه عشر من تشرين
الاول عام 2005 دستورا دائما يؤسسوا
للمواطن
ويضمن كل الحريات
والاهم انه صار السقف الامن الذي يستظل به
العراقيون بعد ان عاشوا تحت ظلال الخوف
والقهر
لتزداد بعدها التحديات
والمخاطر حول التجربه العراقيه
بسبب الارهاب ونبدا مع هذا التحدي مرحله
قاسيه على ابناء شعبنا
فكانت مناظر الجثث الملقات في الشوارع
جراء القتل على الهويه مناظر غريبه على
العراقيين الذين تعايشوا لمئات السنين وهم
يتقبلون بعضهم بلا حساسيه او استنفار
طائفي او كراهيه عنصريه او قوميه
واستمرت بعدها مثل ما كنتم تشاهدون
وتسمعون موجات العنف الطائفي والعصابات
الاجراميه
وعمليات التهجير على الهويه ليصبح العراق
سوقا
لاخبار الموت والقصص المروعه
ثم جاءت صدمه احتلال تنظيم داعش الارهابي
لمناطق واسعه من محافظاتنا شمالا وغربا
حتى اذا ما طرقت ايادي الخطر ابواب بغداد
استنفر العراقيون جميعا بعد فتوى جهاد
الكفائي
ولملموا ما تشتت من شملهم وتزاحمت اكتافهم
على السواتر
ليسطروا اروع القصص عن شعب تجاوز الامه
وجراحه
اشرس معارك التاريخ لتحرير ارضه من اسوا
عصابه ارهابيه
واختلطت دماء العراقيين جميعا
وهب ابن الجنوب والوسط وانتخى ليدفع الضيم
عن اهله في نينوى وصلاح الدين والانبار
ثم بعد ان عبرنا تلك المحنه كانت اثار
التلكؤ واضحه واخذت الشكوى من سوء الاداره
وهدر الاموال بالتنامي حتى شهدنا الكثير
من علامات الصخر ازاء عدم قدره مؤسسات
الدوله على الاصلاح والقيام بواجباتها كما
هو مطلوب
وبعد مخاض عسير جاءت حكومتنا بهذا القدر
من كلمه رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شاه
السوداني في مؤتمر حوار بغداد الدولي
بنسخته الخامسه في ذكرى مرور 20 عاما على
غزو العراق الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]